didn't know that if you shoot someone in
10 people I was like here
dead
[Music]
some of you guys might have seen this
already but there's a video
um that went out a Florida woman in her
own apartment complex working out in her
own gym oh I have seen oh I saw this
dude who just comes up and just randomly
attacks her in her own apartment gym
it's like you know you need a key card
to get in and this guy's just standing
at the door and she lets him in she lets
him in thinking like maybe he's a
resident and forgot his key card so
she's being nice about it
you're like that's not a workout outfit
[Music]
so she's just in there doing her workout
homeboy just comes up to her yeah
approaching me I pushed him I said bro
what the f
ifth chasing me around the bench and we
ended up on the other side whoa [__] so
he was like a homeless dude or does he
live here
yeah she said that she's seen it around
before grateful that she came forward oh
look at that we're gonna take the back
oh my God yeah so she fought him off can
I see the rest of the video at the end
oh you want to see the freaking tactics
all right
to never give up uh my parents always
told me in life to never give up on
anything and that's one thing I always
kept in My Mind
as as long as you don't give up you
fight back
he's so Armstrong that you are one that
you're able to fight back to survive
situation yeah she's probably on that
pre-workout too that's why she's [__]
up yeah she's using barbells Brigade
shower guns
strength stack the reason why she let
him in is because she's seen him around
that area before
but I don't know if he's well he could
be the homeless guy on the same block
exactly yeah and I guess like what they
found out later is that there was like
another time maybe either before or
after that I can't remember which one
that he would just watch people on their
balcony like another person had a report
of
saying like hey this dude's just
watching me from down below looking up
in my balcony and then he showed up at
their door what to do what they didn't
open it so he's not a resident he can't
be yeah he's a local I mean yeah but he
might be he's also walking in there and
he's got [__] what looks like Hotel
slippers on you know what I'm saying he
got a cool Jersey yeah hockey jersey fan
he did have a cool Jersey yes is that
red wings yeah where was that at in
Florida Tampa damn well that's just
regular Florida Behavior though right
it's crazy out there I'm so happy
nothing happened to her though thank God
yeah it is crazy and like the longer
surveillance video and stuff too like
she like opens the door for him she's
like in the middle of her [__] and he
just kind of like chilling around or he
like walks and he stands there and then
she's like going to the other room and
then he's just like standing there for a
second yeah just being creepy yeah it's
just being really weird you know so it's
like obviously also like a really just
improper Behavior it's like something's
kind of loose up there and then even the
way that he like attacks her so to speak
it doesn't seem team
he just seems loopy you know what I'm
saying it doesn't look like he's trying
to [__] put her down because he don't
look like a professional he was he was
trying to take her down bro he picked he
picked up her legs trying to dump her
yeah what was his like goal like was he
trying to like bone in the middle of the
gym or you might be office like rockers
is just like not on his meds but the
thing is like what do you do with
somebody like that you know like like
what's the solution like how do you help
him like afterwards yeah like once you
like what do you do with him do you send
him to jail like how long does he stay
in jail for like California Catch and
Release yeah bro he's gone he's out of
there in California so it's like it's
it's a weird thing you probably ask her
like are you hurt and she would be like
I don't think so in there all right cool
yeah because because he's definitely
like not there yeah right like we talk
about dude he's got a cool Jersey that's
cool that's true I'll take everything
back actually I thought that was a
hockey jersey
that's definitely what he said I think
I'm pretty sure it's not New Jersey it
is it is too when she does get away from
him it's like she like runs out the door
and stuff like that he's still kind of
just like discombobulated it's still
kind of going out there too so it's like
it's it's dope for her to just kind of
like get out of that situation get into
I'm assuming maybe it's like a more
public Street or something like that you
know be able to call for help
um but that's do you ever think about
sometimes
being nice like that opens the door oh
hell yeah 100 so she has a lady right
you got to be really careful how you
move well because being nice doesn't
necessarily mean anything to a person
that's crazy like it doesn't necessarily
mean like all the branches out and
they're like oh they understand or they
pick up you're being nice
they might just be like oh someone's
within my reach it's an entry point form
exactly yeah they're like free candy
yeah sometimes that's what he might be
thinking you know that's kind of why you
have to be careful with like you know
just people that you see out like not
even like strangers but just people that
don't seem right yeah like it's not the
person to be like hey you don't just
start a conversation with them yeah I
could imagine how complex it is if she
isn't aware of that situation or like
who that guy is as like a random you
know stranger who's already gotten some
sort of report and like imagine a dude
that's like you know and you're in like
a metropolitan area or or like a
neighborhood of like you know other
people that are responsible yeah like a
nice complex and maybe a guy's like
knocking on the door you know you also
don't want to be like nah at the same
time but yeah like where's your [__]
game but I do think like people yeah
especially in chicks or people that like
obviously maybe can be physically you
know in trouble they should be like
extra [__] protected girls shouldn't
even take the chance in my opinion yeah
but what if they're afraid to be like
racist or something because they're like
oh I don't want to open up that door
because it's it's for like or I do want
to open up because it's a black guy and
I'm afraid to be a racist yeah but then
the Race part I feel like is in essence
secondary to the safe card to the safety
card right but some not not all people
think that way though oh yeah I agree
well I'm not racist so I'm gonna open
the door for him that happened that
happened to me a little bit when I was
in uh outside the studio in downtown
some uh girl was like knocking on my
window sitting in the car I just don't
talk to people if they try to talk to me
in downtown at all yeah and then she was
like yo I need I needed something like
like roll your window down just roll it
down I'm not rolling I'm like nah just
get the [__] out of here like I cussed
her out and then she was like no I'm not
homeless like she just kept saying I'm
not homeless I was like I don't give a
[__] if you live you're acting like it
yeah that's all this activity yeah and
then like I she like left and walked
down the road and then uh and then like
she was like cussing me out or whatever
she left walk down the street a few
minutes later I finally drove off and
then I saw her um trying to change her
tire at her car three cars down from me
she could still be homeless though you
don't know did you did you pull over and
help her like no man
that I'm not gonna face my fears
you know what makes me
I felt so bad but I'm like hey but again
like it's downtown bro downtown's
different I'm not changing my rules for
nothing even if I was wrong I'm like I
I'm so paranoid I I I could be a racket
it could be a Honeypot it could be like
yo can you help me and then you're like
all right where's your car and you I was
just down here it really could be yeah
and then they're like oh it's in this
alley real quick I just broke down right
here and you're like yeah yeah sure you
walk over and they're like all right
dude Five Guys come up
what do you got in your pocket I got
some Medellin type scam yeah I mean she
clearly had a flat tire and everything
and had the jacket she was the one that
needed like I don't want the Five Guys
to show up but it was odd because she
wasn't saying that she was just like
saying just roll it down just roll it
down I'm like that's a weird way to go
about it anyways like you could easily
sign like I have a flat tire right there
it's like a window it's not like a
[__] soundproof box and it's like to
say like no I'm not homeless it's like
that's weird yeah that's interesting
yeah that's like Dylan got it it's
saying on that stuff well you are a dick
for not helping her
hey but still yeah that sounds crazy
though that happened to me three times
in a row and I was I will not change
I've seen people just take a [__] on the
sidewalk downtown man he's got a couple
videos of that oh my God yeah this dude
is taking a massive dump in front of my
door he pulled he took his jacket off he
was taking a dump in it and I was like
come on man and then he uh he like
bundled up his coat with all the [__] in
it and he like David and Goliath swung
it and it splattered across all the cars
if that were like at the stop sign like
these dudes are still driving oh
I was like that's points for creativity
what do you do with that guy man yeah
like how do we help that guy well he had
this so the district cop who's like the
the Fashion District police officer guy
came over and all he could do was just
beg him to leave he was just like please
just go you already took a [__] like you
can get out of here man I couldn't do
anything about it that's wild and you
still love living in downtown no
man I like living in Lincoln Heights I
don't like living in downtown L.A yo
right down the street from you though
there's like there was some crazy [__]
that went down like right in front of
Bargo like um there was a guy that was
[__] so drugged out he was trying to
come up and open all the doors and he
and then I I felt so like I heard
something in my door I was just chilling
inside of my car and then I look up and
this guy's looking at me with bloodshot
eyes like bald-headed cholo like tatted
up and stuff and he's like trying to
open a door like hella aggressively and
I was like what the [__] turn on my car
and I move a little bit and I just see
what he's doing and he goes and he goes
into
um other other cars right
there's two two guys that was leaving
barbell yeah and then
um you know they're just like regular
dudes like gym goers right and I saw him
like hassle them like like [__] punk
his ass and I was like oh no so I I
busted at you I went back and then I was
in the car and I was like hey what the
[__] so he looked at me and then he's
like [__] yeah and he just started [__]
like coming up to me so I was like oh
[__] so let's change targets yeah I
drove up a little bit but I didn't drive
like hardcore because I wanted him to
follow so then he was following me now
and I was telling those guys like go go
right and then like when I went he would
just chase me and I just [__] bounced
and I looped back around and I went
inside the gym and I was like dude you
know this guy was [__] hassling your
members it was weird man what kind of
drugs do you think he was on it was not
yet normal drugs PCP or some [__] huh
the real question for our hero over here
is where was Bart yeah what the hell
were you doing Bart were you there that
day I know Gio was there he was
when I parked so I drove back in I
parked my car in the back lot when you
guys had that open and I ran in and I
was like like Geo like your members are
they okay because I don't know if they
ran back here or where they went he was
like oh that's just Julio I went to the
front desk let him run around only told
him to call the cops and then like
yeah but that guy was like a creature
like his eyes he was just and then the
guys later we talked to him and they
said that he just smelled like alcohol
and all that he just wanted to fight
yeah yeah I think there's different
rules for people that like clearly look
like they don't follow rules
the rules are out the window and these
ones are in I remember I remember like
uh we were talking about this a long
time ago but I was just in like near uh
Venice Beach area or something like that
it came out of an ice cream shop and
then this homeless dude looks at me he's
like [__] you China man right he's just
going oh like I'm Vietnamese
whatever's convenient
I was like I don't know the rules to
this situation right now because the
dude's like you know I say a slur back
to him or something just walk away dude
it's beyond reason that's the hard part
what do you want me to say though white
guy yeah well he's a very very dirty
white boy yeah yeah so some sort of
white racial slur it might be the same
guy I was in Venice Beach too and it was
his one white dude pulling a [__]
baby carriage basket and then he was
just talking like [__] [__] and then
like get him away get on my way right
and when he saw me he goes ah [__]
Chinese
might have been Nigel and I was like
damn
I think they all have like one like
homeless people they just have like one
look bro if you know it's like One race
have you noticed that it's like what
race are you homeless
it's like Beyond yeah for sure the scary
thing is like the types of crimes when
when there's like that population in the
area the crimes are so weird they're
very like unusual like the one that was
right next to where uh like off of Maine
yeah it was like oh yeah there was a
report of a guy pushing a burning
shopping cart with a woman inside of it
like that's the crime like that is so
odd yeah like it's never like normal
things with a with a clear goal it's
like there's no it's like Mad Libs yeah
it's just they're just doing they're
just doing whatever yeah yeah it's like
bizarre stuff so again like like how she
handled it that's great that she was
able to get away but man not everybody's
here don't open that door bro if you
could be you don't take the chance man
you don't have your key card you gotta
go back upstairs and go get it bro or if
you're alone in there like come on man I
do not miss living in downtown there was
like when I went to sulfite underbelly
he's right on skid roll yeah so yeah
he's right on Skid Row he's down dude he
like just picks people off the streets
and like yeah that's why he can do those
there's tents like all around I don't
know Stanford and fifth or whatever
right like tents everywhere and this
this lady was coming in like giving
blankets to people and then
she I guess she kind of like knocked on
the tent as if it was a door like you
know yeah I guess this guy was kind of
like whatever drugged out and so she
tried to kind of open and be like hello
and then he was just he screamed at her
and this was me just pulling up like
it's like don't [__] touch my house
[__] he's like he was screaming it's
not money but but I swear I heard like a
a gun
and then yeah and then I told Mark I was
like bro and he's like you don't know
Johnny like there's actually people here
who are don't just because they're
homeless it doesn't mean they're not
strapped up and I was like that's crazy
that's crazy yeah because they they're
protecting themselves they're scared and
yeah different set of rules out there
[__] and the guy that reached out who
was under him this other dude he was
like basically saying like because he
lived on skid roll too like before he
got a job and all that and he's like
these people a lot of them don't want
they don't want help they just want to
like they've made a choice to just stay
here and there's also other games things
that kind of act like they're whatever
it's a patrolled area it was crazy bro I
didn't know anything about that wow the
ecosystem's so different that's a whole
thing that I'm interested in because I
know that that's a peace zone for all
the gangs because they all sell drugs so
Bloods Crips everybody they just don't
[__] with the market basically huh yeah
yeah some of those tents are just
businesses yeah yeah the one that was in
front of the one they cleaned up in
front of the brewery remember I told you
I think this dude has her scooter
because it was a Chop Shop yeah that
whole tent was a chop shop so if you
could see people bringing bikes and
motorcycles and then all day long you
just hear the saws the paints they had a
paint booth you hear all that [__] in
the tent yeah no they're doing it
outside the tent oh no they had a school
bus yeah I don't know how yeah but they
had a full old school school bus with
tents and then they had a whole [__]
business there yeah so it looked like a
like a repair shop that was owned by a
homeless person so you know people are
like oh that's nice he has his business
still I'm like yo these people bringing
stolen [__] all day and he's like
chopping them off rest in peace my
scooter but then the cops the cops
finally put a stop to it because uh
someone had shot somebody in a tent
that's the only reason because they're
like I want my headlights back yeah they
didn't care about all the stuff he was
doing until someone got shot and then
they're like okay now we can move on
they didn't know that if you shoot
someone to 10 people I was like here
these heads are pretty thick you're
[__] dead
you heard that don't zip it up
[Music]